thanks for inviting me and okay so today
I'll be talking about not joint work
with all the amazing people will be
talking about works by get done and for
speaker and well we soo in is advisor so
okay and it would be like a light
version talk of obvious when they talk
and get unstuck so you know just sit
back and relax and ask many questions so
the outline is so I'll talk a little bit
about invariant theory and say how it
connects to P IT and then I'll show two
examples and and the two results of four
quick and dirty and macum and then I'll
just talk about open questions and
future work so this would be a more
algebraic side of the developments in
invariant theory that happened recently
okay so again just the the basics again
so if you forgot from I kids talk
already so if V is a vector space in G
is a group acting linearly on it a nice
group let's say you know well we're not
gonna use finite groups we're gonna use
you know continuous groups and connect
it so let's focus on the second example
V is like the set of matrices and then
GX by multiply on the left and right
these are the groups so an invariant
polynomial is the polynomial that
doesn't change under the action of G
right so I mean by now you all know this
so for example in the matrix group here
it's generated by the determinant and
the other object that we are interested
in are the orbits right so is they set
when you apply all the group operations
on a vector V this is the orbit of V and
in the closures right so this is the
orbit with its limit points okay so it's
can be characterized by all the 0 sets
of all the polynomials vanishing on G
acting on V so now the basic questions
that we have I guess we've seen them
through the past days is given a vector
space V and a group G acting on it well
we want to say can we compute the
generators of these invariant
polynomials can we find the relations
among these generators and many other
questions right
but geometrically we can ask the
following question that we have been
asking throughout this week right like
the orbit closure intersection given two
points of the vector space the orbit
closure is intersect right so by a
theorem of Mumford the orbit closures
they do not intersect if and only if
there exists an invariant polynomial
which witnesses this intersection which
means that evaluates differently on both
points okay
so then it's suppose that you have a
basis for the invariance right it
suffice to evaluating set of decision of
a variance it surprises for you to
essentially evaluate on a random linear
combination of these random invariants
right you're gonna get non non zero with
high probability so this is a way that
we could solve this problem by a
randomized algorithm I'm assuming the
groups are really nice and I don't want
to talk about it so yeah like I think
was talked about on Monday already and
all right so okay and then the question
is well how can we deterministic we find
such polynomials and is this the only
way that we can solve it well by now I
think it kind of gave the spoiler of
course not right but okay and in
particular there's an easier problem
writing kittens list of easiest problem
he didn't even mention like write it
down but there's a knock on problem if I
just give you one V and W 0 is 0 in the
orbit closure of your point right so and
now the question is how do these
problems actually relate to PID
right because I'm kid give an algorithm
is completely analytic but how does it
relate to our usual natural vit so let's
see how it happens so ok what is our
input description I would just give you
the group G the vector space V and
they're given by their natural coding
right so if I give you like GL n you
know I just give you the matrices right
and of the generators and V are just
give us the coefficients like the usual
vector space representation Oh
so for example let's say I have one
group GL n and have matrix V and then I
just give you the matrices and I give my
input matrix as an element of the vector
space and the action is clear here the
conjugation
okay now again problems of interest we
have the null cone problem orbit closure
intersection again efficiently and well
do to Catan right how to succinctly
compute the generators of the coordinate
ring and if you can actually do it and
also the orbit closure containment right
which Marcus talked about and other
people also talked about so okay again a
couple of remarks just to reinforce is
that the null cone problem in the orbit
closure intersection problem they are
witnessed by invariant polynomials right
so we can we can solve them by using
polynomials this is special felonious
now the orbit closure containment seems
much harder right and I mean mark is
proof that it's a np-hard for the case
of tensors right so and but examples of
orbit closure containment problems is
the VP barabash this being people are
problem and also like border rank as as
as Markus talked about okay but for this
talk well since we're interested in
polynomials let's only study the
problems that were polynomials appear
okay so okay now so what are the basic
structure of questions and results right
I mean variant theorists were interested
on these questions like since this field
started and one of them is the first one
is this ring finitely generated right
there was the result of Hilbert that yes
this ring is finitely generated so we
have a finite number of generators that
we need to find so we can test whether
orbit closures intersect or not right
can we have complexity bounds on the
generator so our dis generators hard to
compute and the first question was well
can we give upper Brown even on the
degrees of the generators of this set
right because if you had a generator of
exponential degree then you have no hope
to evaluate it even right so the theorem
is a popov and then Dirks and the this
improvement well you have exponential
degree bounds and as I've mentioned on
Monday these are tight from from any
group actions right and the other one is
can we construct these invariants in
certain generality and I guess as was
mentioned a little bit in on kids talk
the answer is yes you
use the railroads operator and you have
you have ways of constructing them so we
have the Haley Omega that get dimension
and there's also the Casimir operator so
we have some structure results and some
algorithmic results but they're not that
great right so for example the rain odds
operator is very general but it's not
efficient it does not give you very nice
polynomials to work with you need
something more I think it mentioned a
little bit in the end of his talk
so for algorithms we really if we want
to do PR T we really need simple
invariants right we need invariants I
mean VP let's say maybe I can explain
offline yeah it's a bit it's not
something we didn't half an hour that I
can do it do more stuff yeah I can tell
you everything later so yeah so yeah and
well I mean we have exponential degree
bound so even for restricted cases if we
want to do restricted P items like this
restricted P a check for null count an
orbit closure intersection well we need
polynomial degree bounds right if we
expect to do another break way it's hard
to prove better degree bounds even for
special cases so for example for the
operator scaling case that I had talked
about polynomial bands were only proved
in 2016 or like late 2015
and you know before all these words that
that we talked about without get you
know the previous algorithms for knock
on an orbit closure intersection they
were W exponential okay so we want to
improve on this thing so now let's see
how PID appears in our you know natural
way like the way that we're accustomed
so okay I know that we have to talk
about separating variance now but let me
just talk about the most basic yeah so
since there's an introduction so in DC
t5 normally defined this the right
complexity version of seeing the
coordinate ring okay which is this idea
of 16 generators so if I pick a
coordinate ring so this is the ring of
all the invariant polygons
for the group action okay we say that
this in very engraving ring it has and
let's see be like a simple circuit class
okay think of CSV P okay it has a six
extinct generators if there is a small
circuit F on the variables V so V is the
variables of the vector space
okay let's think of X 1 up to X N and Y
are some auxiliary variables okay so
this circuit here belongs to the circuit
class C such that when I write the
polynomial computed by the circuit okay
it can be written in the sum of f IV x
GI on the variables y so the you know
you can write them in a separate way
where all of these F is when you collect
this sum here this set is a set of
generators of your coordinate rate ok
and these polynomials they are linearly
independent
right so essentially one a way to to
encode all the invariants by a small
circuit at once right and what captain
after captain defined this well you said
if see if this ring has C 16 generators
then the null cone an orbit closure
intersection can be solved simply by so
VPI T for the Class C because remember
there's the theorem of Mumford that if
you have two orbit closures they do not
intersect if and only if you have one
invariant right and here you he's giving
us a way of efficiently accessing a
random invariant so far so good
okay so again so to test it appoint you
is in the now code is essentially to
test if f when I substitute this V by
you write this whole polynomial here in
the variables y is equal to 0
identically equal to 0 and the test
orbit close your intersection again I
just substitute V by U and V by W here
take the difference and I do another Pap
test yeah okay so well as a remark you
know usually if you wanna do this again
algebraically you want C to have
polynomial degree bounds right but the
analytic approach that n Kate showed may
sometimes not need these degree bounds
right so for example the works that
we've talked about right we don't need
we don't need like polynomial degree
bounds but for orbit closure
intersection like that we don't know
right so all the algorithms that we know
so far they do need polynomial degree
bounds as we see also the fact that that
categorical quotient is explicit in a
relaxed answer this is a major point of
the analytic reports maybe didn't stress
it enough you don't need to know what
some of the environments we just need
but then you go to the general
representations I believe this would
break down at some point I'm not so yeah
we don't know but I mean so far like it
could soak it and it could be possible
that you only need like the you can use
the Kissimmee process and you can just
get like properties for orbit closure
intersection is is a different game but
we also don't know yeah it's a but even
here already shows up like for example
for know for any parent in the relaxed
sense here but I just want to keep it
simple okay so now let's see one out
like two different algebraic examples on
how to do vit for restricted classes of
this general problem that
define yeah so the first one will be the
simultaneous conjugation problem so what
is the setup here so here I have only
one group which is the special in your
group all the invertible matrices
determine one and my vector space is m
tuples of n by n matrices complex
matrices ok and the action is again I
act by conjugating by the same element
okay yeah because you substitute instead
of these in numbers anyway that's not a
limiting popular it's just a degree of
thing very important ah music method if
I can have for this yeah you're right
yeah for this just the GI s-- can have
small degree just small circuits it's
gonna get the GI have smelled the green
why this I think I think I think I think
I think when he mayn't it's like they're
the circuit the circuit computes F but
like it can be exponential in the big
like the degree of the variables V in
the circuit could be exponential and
yeah so this is fine yeah as long as the
degree of the Y's are polynomial I think
it should be okay yeah
okay so okay so back to the set up so we
have the simultaneous conjugation and
again the null cone problems I just give
it to pull of matrices and you know I
want to know if they evaluate to zero
and all the invariants and the orbit
closure intersection again I want to see
if there's any variant that evaluates
differently on that okay so for this
case we have a really nice description
of the invariants okay which are given
by purchase IRA's miss love and for my
neck and we also have degree bounds so
that they were generated by these
polynomials so trace of the products of
these matrices like X 1 up to xn so you
pick all the combinations all the words
okay so think of it as a word of length
up to N squared and take their product
and you take the trace so all of these
polynomials generate the invariants for
for this action ok so this is a really
nice description and ok so yeah we have
polynomial degree bounds and now the
question is is this set like of
generators extent right yeah it's a
maybe I should brown rice is not that
old and rustboro was not that old I
think so yes maybe yeah okay so okay so
for the simultaneous conjugation okay so
we know these generators and now how are
they succeed
well sixth sentence you know Inge is 85
and then for for s for book also
observed they're essentially can be
computed by read once a BP okay and how
do you do it well essentially pick these
matrices like ZJ okay so ZJ will be the
first one here and then you put like a
fresh variable YJ 0 for the identity and
then you put YJ i for the matrix x i
okay and once you have it wants to
compute the trace of only this product
z1 up to CN squared okay you're going to
get monomials here which well we know
that they're linearly independent right
times the trace exactly of this word x
i1 up to x IL okay
so it's an easy exercise and I already
gave the hint
the blanks here they don't need to get
cut up so essentially the only thing is
that this is a read once a BP okay so
okay so how do we solve it now we have
succinctness and the sixth sentence is
really nice and again by Mumford is
enough to check given two points right
if the circuit is different from zero
right so okay and again this polynomial
is 0 if and only if all the invariants
agree right because you have each of
them are encoded by a monomial okay so
four straight but this is a read once
MEP then you know right by right speaker
we have a white box vit in P and a black
box p18 quantity okay
so since we all know read or say vp's
I'm not gonna go over this proof I want
to go about the next proof which is a
little more interesting you know any
questions it can s be su because it's
his work so all right so now let's talk
about the left/right action again which
is the operator scaling action right so
here the group is a Cartesian product of
SL ends our vector spaces again a tuple
of matrices and the action of gh is
again you pre multiply by G and post
multiply by H okay there's the minus one
just because of the group action right
okay so and then we have knock on in
orbit close intersection and let's just
talk about the orbit close intersection
from now on now the invariants okay so I
put the people who came up with the
invariants here the older people and
then you have the new people that gave
the degree bounds right and they're very
recent so these invariants they're
generated by these funny-looking
polynomials here and what are these
polynomials they're essentially
determinants of so these Y is okay for
each D we have a fresh matrix Y ID which
is a D by D matrix okay so think of this
as the fresh new variables that we have
okay and we take this determinant of the
Y I D tensor power with X I okay so
these are the invariants and it's enough
to take matrices of size of dimension D
for D less than or equal to n to the
fifth okay so there's the invariants
they become a little more involved than
the previous ones right and I
the p80 question is well ate and I'll
put this like not equivalent and not
equivalent is it the orbit closures
don't intersect okay a is not equivalent
to B if and only if there exists some D
right such that this polynomial is
different from zero right where wise are
the variables now okay and I substitute
the tuple a and the tuple B by by X okay
and if you want to encode all of it
that's a 1 PID question just add a fresh
variable Z right to keep track of all
the so anyways if you're if you really
insist that you need to have one
polynomial okay so okay so before we
talk about the orbit closure intercept
I'm not going to talk about succinctness
here I'm just going to talk about a
different approach of solving this
problem okay which is the Dirksen macum
approach
so now let's first talk about the
knock-on what do we know about the knock
oh okay so okay and before let me give a
spoiler so how do how are we gonna solve
this action did know come from orbit
closure intersection is by a reduction
there's a poly time reduction from the
left/right action to the simultaneous
conjugation action okay so this is like
in a very sense it is a kind of
complexity theoretic kind of proof which
was not done by complexity theorists
right unless this is comforting I mean
not sure so but before let's talk about
the null cone algorithm okay so what do
we know about this well we have an hour
and a little rhythm didn't get just
showed okay so we can decide membership
in the na koni polynomial time and again
for this approach don't need the upper
bound the degrading variants and but
there's also not a break algorithm by
Ivana's Jo and Subramanian right then
they decide membership in the Napali
time so okay so and I like us they can
decide membership in the na koni point
of time and moreover they can also find
if a is not in the now cone they can
explicitly find some matrices y1 up to Y
D such that you know the determinant
polynomial that funny polynomial is
different from zero okay so they can
find this matrix and this would be
important for us okay okay so now that
we know the null cone which is a basic
route subroutine let's let's prove orbit
closure intersection now via reduction
okay and this is the works of dirt N and
V so so okay so suppose our input is
given by matrices of the rational
entries and okay we know orbital
intersection for simultaneous
conjugation how can we get how can you
get this reduction right so okay this is
their theorem okay
orbit closure intersection for left
right action is actually equivalent to
orbit closure intersection at politie
under poly time reduction okay so this
is a first like reduction in invariant
theory I guess well efficient reduction
there was a less efficient reduction
before for people who know quivers so
okay let's do the easy direction right
like orbit closure intersection for
simultaneous conjugation okay well you
know my time reduces to orbit closure
intersection for left/right action okay
and this reduction here is very simple
right
so if okay so this equivalence and if I
put FC is under simultaneous conjugation
and the equivalence LR is the left right
action right so okay so the reduction is
just this so this tuple of matrices
right is equivalent to this one the
orbit colors intersect under the
simultaneous conjugation if and only if
well I just append an identity matrix
here right and this these orbit closure
intersect under this under the
left/right action why well because if
you look at the identity here right like
you're essentially forcing G and H to be
the same right so you have the
conjugation action so so that's the
proof here so that's pretty easy now
let's go to the heart direction right
which is orbital intersection for left
right action reduces to orbital
intersection for 17s conjugation so now
okay so let's just use some easy facts
right we can test that the determinant
of each matrix AI is equal to the
determinant of each matrix bi for eyes
otherwise we have any variant that shows
that they're not different so let's you
know get rid of these cases and the
orbit closure intersection does not
change if we replace an input a 1 up to
am by any other element on its orbit
right because they're still talking
about the same two orbits ok so far so
good is it just very easy facts so let's
see how they do the reduction so okay
what is the easy case here suppose that
one of the tuples that you have a 1 up
to M is in the now cone okay
in this case I mean we know how to test
it in polynomial time so orbital
intersection is equivalent to the knock
on problem then we can just use the
algorithms and put a big P ok now what
is the other easy case is that suppose
that my first matrix a 1 ok has
determined different from 0 and remember
the determinant of AI is equal to
determinant of B I so the determinant of
B 1 is also different from 0 ok then
this left/right action here right the
orbit closures intersect if and only if
let's pick a different point in their
own orbits right I can essentially use
this point here notice that I'm just
multiplying every one just on the left
by a 1 inverse right so then I have this
point here which is in the orbit of a 1
up to M and I have this point here in
the orbit of B 1 M 2 p.m. right so so
this these orbits colors are equivalent
if and only if these are equivalent
right but again we saw before that these
orbits are equivalent if I have the
identity if and only if the if I shrink
the tuples these other tuples are
equivalent under the simultaneous
conjugation action yeah so that's the
easy case right and it's easy to adapt
this easy case when we have the span of
a is it has an invertible matrix and we
know
the the divertible matrix okay in this
patch so if I gave you like okay there's
a linear combination here's a linear
combination of this matrices that is
invertible we also know how to do that
case okay so let's just assume that and
keep going so what is the remaining case
well rainy case is that they both tuples
they're not in the novel and they do not
spend any variable matrix right so now
well what's the plan the plan is to
reduce to this previous easy case okay
but for that we need blow-ups okay and
water blow ups here's the definition so
if I have a tuple of matrices okay so
it's gate order blow up is essentially
you take each matrix a I and it tells
rate with this elementary matrix that
has only a 1 in the JK entry okay and
you do that for all of the matrices m
and all the JK oh I have two K's anyways
all JK's in the blow up yeah okay so
it's a lemma from Dirk's and become that
if I have two tuples of matrices with
rational entries and K is large enough
and you can pick one K that you like a
so the orbit closure intersection
problem so a and B the orbit colors
intersect if and only if their orbit
closures of these blow-ups intersect
okay and they blow up is not that it's
not that big right so you can write
these efficiently okay so what is the
remaining case okay they're not in the
null cone and the size of the input is
blowing up by K squared in this I mean
yes yes but kek is small right so yeah
yes so okay so now so we know the a and
B are not in the now cone and well we
know that they don't spend any matrix so
in particular these determinants are
zero right but a not being the null cone
we need oh thanks
so a is not in the know cone then we
know that their exists matrices in
particular dimension n minus 1 or even
higher right such that this polynomial
does not vanish right by what we saw in
the invariants so we know we can find
and we can find these matrices by the
IQs algorithm so in particular if you
look at the N minus 1 blow-up it has an
invertible element right and all the
other blow ups will have invertible
elements okay so now let's use this
lemma the Dirks amacom lemma to reduce
the blown East Diploma in us 2
simultaneous conjugation oh no that's it
right so yeah my previous cases so I
have the I have a blow-up there has
there has an invertible element and i
know how to find any variable matrix in
the span of these blow-ups so remember
if I go to my previous case in the slide
here right is exactly the other case
that I know how to handle right because
I'm also given to you the invertible
matrix in the span ok so this finishes
the reduction all right so just map them
to the blow ups and from the blow ups
and the span of the invertible matrix
you can find an instance a larger
instance of the simultaneous conjugation
action yeah and then once you reduce the
simultaneous conjugation action you can
do the read once ABP vit intersection of
exactly it's like the reduction to the
null corner - yeah so ok and now let me
just mention a little bit the different
algorithm right the analytic result
which doesn't go by reduction right then
since then keep didn't talk about it so
we can just mention some details here so
we can decide orbit closure intersection
in poly time there's a joint work with
the z11 ket I want G and a V and so now
for orbit closure intersection here we
do also just like Dirk's anima come we
also need the polynomial degree bounds
and here's the outline so one kid showed
us how to scale anything that can be
scaled to W stochastic how to scale very
close to doubly stochastic right so
suppose that we could just scale that
directly to double stochastic okay so
stake scaling to double stochastic takes
us to the element of minimum norm in the
orbit closure right as I mentioned the
optimization problem in his slide right
like NIV talked about it on Monday so
suppose that V tilde and W tilde they
are the elements of minimum norm that we
found in both orbits
okay so they may not be the same but
there's a result by cam finesse that
these orbit closures intersect if and
only if these elements of the new norm
they're equivalent under rotations okay
and by rotation here just means that an
action of the Maxima compact subgroup
which in our case would be like just
products of unit Aries so it's
essentially rotations right and then we
just need to test if this points they're
equivalent under these rotations and we
have an algorithm for doing that but a
remark well analytic approach right we
only get approximate results right at
this point and to solve these
approximations it's very cumbersome and
we had to do a lot of work as opposed to
this beautiful reduction that I just
showed you okay so it's just a one page
and I have zero minutes yeah sorry we
need because of the approximations here
like we need to get like exponentially
closed so if you had explanation BAM you
need to get double exponential close to
two just for the no con we just need one
over epsilon here is a different set now
and we need to get exponentially close
and we I mean we're lucky that we can
get exponential because of polynomial
degree bounds if you had exponentially
gibran have to get I can explain to you
since I have zero minutes or minus one
let me just say the open question so so
okay so here's can we create a
complexity theory for this computational
problems in a very theory can we have
these efficient reductions between like
different group actions right so you
know there are semi come show that you
know these problems are equivalent like
seven simultaneous conjugation
left-right action can we find complete
problems can I don't know right like can
we have more applications of these
algorithms as kids said we know we don't
have applications for tens or scaling
even right then well what is the
difference between analytic methods in
algebraic methods like which one is the
strongest right and thank you because
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]